Nếu đã phần anh, thời gian qua, tại khu dù lịch hiện sân sống sống nhà, thục vấn quốc gia báo vi,
xuất hiện nhiều công chính xây dực.
Đào lý dài của lãnh đạo với cuộc gia báo vi,
thì các hỏa tự trên nhằm khác phục hợp qua,
tựng bảo số bà, nằm hãy in không trẤn thái lịch dựng.
Vy nhìn, biểu đáng quan tâm, là quy định về việc tiến hành cải tạo,
khách phục, được thực hiện như thế nào, có cần giấy phép hay không?
Chỉ biết rằng, công ty của phần tập loàn xây dực và suy lịch miếng,
đơn vị quan lý khu dù lịch hiện sân sống nhà,
sau gần một năm vẫn chưa có phần anh khách phục tự thể.
Bộ tuổi đồng vị về chủ trời.
Các phục và phố ngu họ,
về dây khác thì,
mấy vừa anh, mấy dây đồng vị,
cái chào hỏa khách phục,
mấy mấy mặc tự bị và tự thật phục.
Trời là hỏa chưa ở em, phụ anh không?
Vào đại, thì về ở trong tội đồng vị,
yêu có hoàn thiện.
Rử lộn đặt công hỏa,
liệu không có phần anh của thể,
thì con tươi đâu để vấn khúc ra bà bị,
kiểm soát quá trình xen rực của sánh dợp.
Và liệu, con tư bình mình,
có trình thủ quá trình khách phục hộ quảm gử báo,
để kiến thành thêm các hoạch tập xen rực khác hay không?
Đây là câu vượt suy chàng của hạt sân,
được mở giống đủ vị tâm.
Bây giờ bên phải câu,
trước đây không có đường,
những ngày đã làm sông phần nên đường
và tiến thành làm mạo đường.
Bên tà lý dương của đường đã được kẻ đã
tầm chương ra, khoảng hơn 200 mẹ,
giống khoảng 800 mẹ.
Khách phục như vậy,
thì có,
đầu đánh,
có thể là họ cũng làm quá khương cà cái.
Để kiểu
mà các cuộc mồ sống đoạn.
Bộ cuộc đồ với tông như phủ đình và xe.
Khi kể đây là các pháp tình của không có pháp mình,
cái này,
vàu, cái mà,
mà mà khác của báo thì họ cũng làm nó hơi quảm.
Trong báo cáo của người cưng ra bà bị,
rồi gần của báo xuống là,
khu dù lịch có 200 mẹ đường bị sát lợp.
Quả thông tin người dân cùng cấp,
có nhiều việc chỉ,
của bật được tiếng hành thị công sây dật
ở trước thời điểm báo xuống bà người anh hợp.
Hảnh chiếm,
đâm hành hình không trong 200 mẹ đường.
Thật chỉ là ngoài phương hắn,
khoảng lý báo ôn và phát triển mình đứng quên cuộc ra bà bị,
ra đoạn hành hình không trong 200 mẹ,
200 mẹ đường.
Còn nỗi thủ dừng xam mục,
giảng hãng hãng năm,
của ngoạc sơn,
đường xuống hạc sơn.
Được lồ biết tông,
và người mùng xau tháng 5,
500 mẹ đường.
Chưa dài,
khoảng 300 mẹ,
bình nâng,
và mẹ.
Chính thương hắn 200 mẹ
không trong 200 mẹ
hành hình không trong 300 mẹ
đây là đường đất nhỏ.
Đường mòn thì trong dường.
Đường từ khu sông nhà hành trù sơn
ra gản 5 của ngoạc sơn
được tổ vét tông phần thiệt
với chưa dài hương vầy trong mẹ.
Bình nâng,
đường thí công từ tháng 2,
300 mẹ đường.
Chính thương hắn 200 mẹ
500 mẹ,
đây chỉ là đường mòn nhỏ.
Bạn dọc xuống từ gà nghĩa hạ sơn lên chúng sơn.
Bình phải xuống dài khoảng 300 mẹ.
Bình nâng,
2 mẹ,
với bà mẹ.
Đợt này không có trong phương hắn
nhưng được bắt đầu thí công,
những tháng 2 năm hành hình chúng trong 200 mẹ.
Bình trải xuống,
5 trong phương hắn,
2 đường đất.
Nhưng thực tế,
đặt được độ với tông,
1 năm,
1 năm hành hình chúng trong 200 mẹ.
Bối bây giờ khoảng 500 mẹ
có đọc xuống hông,
1 trong phương hắn được phía dưới.
1 năm,
1 kẻ là.
Hình hành này,
cái nhận thủy tháng bài.
Nói hành hình phương hắn 200 mẹ.
Cù bài đồ xe,
1 tô chung sơn,
1 xe dựng cố.
Trước năm 200 mẹ,
vẫn là dựng cây vào phủy.
Bà chỉ có đường mòn trong người đi bộ.
Tuy nhiên,
tự giữa năm 200 mẹ,
nơi đây bắt đầu bị xanh gà
và đồ đường bê tộc đi giữa.
Bình hành.
Cù này đã trở thành bài đồ xe,
1 tô,
1 tôn.
Tró bà đồ bị tinh,
1 phạm vi hút dù liết thường xe gà.
Những đường mòn xanh nước biển,
và Sinh giương.
Đại đường đất,
hiện hữu,
theo phương hắn đã được phía dưới.
Những đường mòn být này,
thì hiện đường đất,
được mở thêm.
Nằm ngoài thương hắn.
Bị kẻ đó,
những đường đỏ,
cũng nằm ngoài thương hắn đã được đồ biết tâm.
Đường mòn hắn,
đường mòn hắn,
đường đất,
những đã được đồ hiệu,
Mặc dù chưa được thậm dưới các fan sây dựng
Bây giờ con quân tâm là những hoạt động sây dựng đó đúng với điện này không?
Thao, cái một năm sau vào cái kinh tinh mốt, sờ rồi
Nhìn một năm sau, thì nếu mà cho phép đi
Họ không chứa chưa, chưa phép
Dạ, bảo dạ đi đi
Bây giờ mình này họ, có xây dựng các bạn không chỉ nhau mà
Bây giờ mình bảo lập mình bản mà
Về cái việc là xây dựng không đúng phản vì rồi xây dựng không đúng cái không chỉ
Mặc n texture trọng những phép trường bảo lập người
Bây giờ mình bảo lập người
Bây giờ mình vào đúng là
Bây giờ mình đó, cho chúng tôi đã cố gắng
V serious
Bây giờ mình có giải quyết này tất cả
Mựa ím khi anh biết được
Bây giờanson nó rất so hấp nhá
Bây giờ mình sẽ được Để bảo vệ hông
Bây giờ mình có một hông
cho phần bạn số 2 chăm, để mừng sáo tháng 7,
năm 2020, vẫn có ra bà bị nếm y công ty mình mình
phải dừng ngay các hoạt động xanh cả,
dây dịch tập đình quán, các hoạt động phải chục sự điều trình của bật lắm nhật
và các phần bản cứu rất là.
Tào hợp đồng số không một,
vẫn có ra bà bị chỉ cho cụt thì mình mình
theo 1 trình dừng năm 2020,
khi tổng dịch tòi thuy ra,
hãy chăm năm 2020,
chỉ được khi công tối ra,
phải bà năm 2019,
dịch tích các công trình.
Tuy nhiên, theo thống kê của Huếc Quốc gia bà bị,
đến ngày May 2, 2019,
người tham thẳng xấu năm 2020,
khu dụi lịch xanh xuống nhà đã xây dự
tảm với bẩy yình, 2 chăm năm 2019,
phải 3 người bốt bếc thuộc,
bao hôm hạt động xấu thông của công trị xây dự khác.
Như vậy, các số điều này,
tình đến dựa tham xấu năm 2019,
công ty mình mình đã sấm phạm hơn một phẩy mốt hết ra đất dừng nặ rộn,
theo để ăn體 đi ở được việc.
Tào tống kê, khi nhận vào phẩm viên,
đến tháng 6 năm 2020,
còn số này đã vui thóa mởi giám thạm.
Vậy, dựa vào đâu để trong xuất thời gian trải,
công ty mình mình đến hãy xây dựa nhiều công trình phí trở được khác như vậy.
Bởi vì năm 2020,
chính phủ và bộ đông nghiệp và phát triển thông thôn,
này là bộ đông nghiệp và bộ trởi.
Lần nữa, phê dựa để ăn體 điểm,
sự dụng hô chính dựng đặc dụng,
để kinh ra in dịch bộ dụi lịch và giáng dụng nghiệp,
tại phần Quốc gia bà bị.
Tựa giả gì điểm,
cũng đăng hãy yーホng trong trải,
để năm hãy nhìn của trong bệnh.
Công ty mình mình đến giảm thí điểm này,
đến tháng các hoạt động xây dựa xuất thời gian qua.
Không được.
Bây giờ thì vui cũng có ý,
mà các tức tục tý điểm,
nhưng mà,
cái năng quan đẹp của quản mý vừa,
là hãy nhìn của trong mấy cám,
quy định chi tiết thị hành một số điều của một lắm nghiệp,
là hãy nhìn của trong bệnh bệnh.
quy định rất gió.
Dịt tích các công trình phục vụ phát triển dụi xin thái,
trong môn trường dân không được của quả hai phần chăm,
tẩu tiện tích môn trường dựa phê.
Trường hợp tẩu tiện tích xây dựa công trình,
phục vụ xù lịch xin thái,
ý dưỡng, gại chi,
vượt quả quy định gại dựa này.
Vì mang nhân dân cấp tình,
cạnh tử và tình thình thức phyến,
và tính chất,
quy môn trường an của thế.
Ôi bên bản đến nghĩ,
rửi bộ nông nhật và phát triển phần con,
để báo tạo thủ đúng chính phủ xem xem chắc sạch sạch sạch sạch.